[Music]
another episode of another one the
[ __ ] I like these very much we're
just hanging people but I like it cuz
everyone has like very different
opinions yeah okay
all right I like this one when I've been
the [ __ ] if I ask my pregnant wife to
move out because she and her best friend
decided to test my loyalty Wow I judged
it harshly at the top and think I'm on
this guy's side why would you wanna kick
out your pregnant wife yeah Nicki's
ready she's like okay that's fine it's
like can we can I keep my pregnant wife
because she farts a lot at night now
that's legit honestly banish those are
pregnant farts
maybe they're 44 - yes - [ __ ] it make it
Pleasant though oh my god I hate that
when they're like I'm eating for two
[Laughter]
okay all right deep breath everyone my
wife is pregnant with our daughter
initially we were really happy and
excited about it but then she starts
acting like a nut job she gets angry
magnets hated for small things and she's
like even a witch she doesn't like the
food I make starts acting insecure and
accuses me of losing attraction for for
example she was pregnant she wanted to
eat chicken sandwiches for dinner last
week well I made chicken sandwiches so
she eats all the sandwiches leaves me
with nothing and then told me that
tasted like [ __ ] piss because she left
me nothing but if she didn't like them
why did she have to eat everything baby
she's eating fruit too
when I asked her this she told me that
she was hungry okay fine she does this
every time eats everything I make and
then calls it [ __ ]
I don't argue with her because I work
for more than 80 hours a week and I
really want to have some peace when I'm
at home so yesterday a random girl
starts flirting with me after the gym
and asked me if I wanted to meet up with
her for some drinks I rejected her and
told her I was married and then when I
got home my wife started to hug me and
apologize when I asked her what happened
she told me that her best friend
suggested a test for my loyalty oh so
they asked a mutual friend to flirt with
me at the gym and asked me out and I
passed yay just kidding I'm really
pissed would I be the axle a bastard
move out okay wait what first of all
that was really wrong over your wife to
do yes and if she wasn't pregnant and
pumped with hormones beyond her control
I would say you would absolutely kick
her out and where she [ __ ] up was she
probably wasn't hot enough not hot
enough thank you Joe you gotta get your
hottest friend probably outsource to get
a hot girl I know you're not my type
thank God I'm married yeah oh you mean
the flirting friend was
my god they were just like who should we
get I think Sally's free okay let's call
Sally she's like a four that was like
five drinks with a man and there's like
no thank you ma'am she's like sorry sir
no ma'am she is
she needed to get multiple hot women
yeah - scenarios cuz you don't know what
his type is dress I'm hot - all the
different types that's enough - that
[ __ ] that's how hormonal she is well you
know imagine there's just one day it's
your normal Trek from the gym back home
and just these women like did I get
hotter
no no he's like he's like this shirt is
getting worn more okay but let's wait
let's let's roll it back and that's like
really dive into this so I guess the
thing that that what's odd to me is what
really was pissing this guy office she
keeps eating all the [ __ ] food like
[ __ ] everybody that probably hurts his
feelings because he does all this stuff
for her and then she turns around and
[ __ ] berate some flooring but also I
was this dude said he is working 80
hours a week right 80 hours a week
he needs to order post mates and then he
won't take it personally and then he
doesn't have to cook the food
yeah he's working two jobs might be
making ends meet
yeah and then he comes home and makes
her dinner yeah judo chick-fil-a is like
three dollars go through youtube it
adjusts struggling father
hit post mates come home from work
you're 80 hours you make your wife
dinner yeah and she's like pregnant
belly hanging out of a crop top and
she's like tastes like [ __ ] nikki goes
up to a homeless guy on the side of the
road and he's like he's like i'm hungry
and she's like me and when they show up
he's like it was v like no it was okay
that's like his main problem but guys
we're getting to the meat of it so then
he puts it he's already [ __ ] annoyed
my man has overworked overstressed i
here cooking meals a little ungrateful
you know you know why he wanted to kick
her out the house though so he can
actually bring the girl from the gym
back to the you still want those drinks
yeah he's like after he finds out he's
like oh that's so wrong hey you still
want to hang out afterwards and come
over the house and huh you know why also
he probably couldn't afford to buy
drinks you know so he was like I'm
married yeah I really want those drinks
that she came back she came to him like
super proud too like what kind of answer
did chicks back from him you bastard
he's like oh cool that's great
I totally bout that our marriage is
better than ever she possibly expect me
I'm saying if this was a non-pregnant
situation this guy I mean he has every
right to be mad as is but but like the
girl it [ __ ] with your minds but look
or her friends all pregnant because they
should have had
they should have been like gonna talk to
her down there crazy it was their idea
it was their idea at all divorced was
like you should [ __ ] get him trapped
like what the [ __ ] yeah he's probably
thinking like men if I'm gonna stay with
her I had to stay with all of her
friends and they're all crazy so he's
just trying to get out of this right cuz
her her good friends should have been
like no this is a bad idea she's the one
that was their idea
pregnant ass to be paranoid you know
what he should have done is get like a
ripped ass pool boy to go to the house
and start hitting on his wife from the
backyard and see if she passes that [ __ ]
because she's the one that wants to feel
more attractive yeah Steve she doesn't
pass then get another pool boys they'll
be like know what she'll if she fails it
and then could you be like and you walk
in and stake a pool boys suck it out her
teeth and you're like you were supposed
to go all the way
[ __ ] actually do it dude report back
to me he's like oh my god that's like
Pete what's his name with character all
nessuno the Chad guy is that all right
oh sweet he's like the girls like come
on Chad give me someone who's like
alright yeah okay I mean but I think
okay but if he exid kicks her out though
he's the [ __ ] right you should at
least wait until she has I would leave
the house she's creating a human inside
her you would lead the house of that no
I instead of kicking her out I'd leave
the house because for me I'm thinking
about my kid yeah yeah yeah chicken
sandwiches for her yeah she has to make
her own [ __ ] she's gotta figure out what
to do I'm not gonna service her anymore
she might have a belly but she got
choice was to leave I would have kick
her out yeah I would just leave if you
get to compose nice new customer code
you can get a free thirty dollars one
hundred dollars so maybe referral codes
there's a lot of ways we could work
around this yeah but isn't that drastic
though to like divorce just yeah but but
the reaction to I've been kicking her
out of the house is pretty much divorce
right
for sure but kicking her out of the
house I mean that's obviously he's
looking to end the relationship but
there's a really key factor here the
title of this size would I be the
[ __ ] if I asked my pregnant wife to
move out because she and her best friend
decided to test my loyalty the person
that put this together was her best
friend which means he knows he's about
to have to deal with these [ __ ]
forever
I don't want to deal with that [ __ ]
forever I might cut it off that needs to
be a huge conversation then maybe since
you got shitty friends yeah yeah it's
not just tell your [ __ ] dumbass bimbo
friend to come over here we're gonna
have a conversation beat her ass oh no
no I'll call both to beat around yeah
just start trouble around it buy some
[ __ ] face people though yeah yeah but
the chicken sandwich part can we back up
to that because was it the popeyes
chicken sandwich she's pregnant and like
when I'm when I'm PMSing I could be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but before like before I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I tell him I'm like a PMSing
a curfew myself being a [ __ ] right now
but I just I get a warning shot every
week that this is where every week every
week it's PMS with everyone so month the
week that it not every week I get one
every Monday it's actually this week
right now thank you I actually feel
really good right now yeah when it's a
PMS like symptom like my blood starts to
boil and it's just like it's over the
stupidest [ __ ] we did that thing with
your eye with that thing what thing
bones that thing you know but okay no
matter here's my thing as a woman
because I have really bad PMS too no
matter how bad of a week we are having
there's that anger there's that you know
just whatever but you have room for
gratefulness and what I'm hearing here
is this man it's like I'm working 80
hours a week and coming home and cooking
you dinner and you don't appreciate it
be a [ __ ] all day but like say like
okay [ __ ] the same psychic I'm sorry I'm
PMSing like yeah you just said your
knowledge eyes and at least say thank
you for putting out the entitlement and
the unapologetic behavior toward it's
like when you use the PMS as an excuse
to be an [ __ ]
that's what's not yeah that's that
devil's advocate really quick 80 hours a
week away from her because he's working
she feels unattractive already maybe her
love language is physical touch or
something that makes her feel attractive
and because he's away 80 hours it's just
spiraling in her in her head like he's
not attracted to me he doesn't want to
touch me he doesn't want to be around me
she's probably know so she feels even
then when he's home he's cooking her
sandwiches but they're still not
spending time with each other and her
aggression is like that she just doesn't
feel attractive so she's saying the
chicken sandwiches were [ __ ] but really
it wasn't about the sandwiches yeah she
wanted quality time she want to be
hugged what is it he can think about
your food he does not propose doubt you
mean the Tabasco soup why don't cook for
Nikki because she gets post mates
[Music]